what makes the difference between the
successful
your successes and your failures as a
coach
a range of reasons the single most
important is persistence
people will point to all kinds of
virtues amongst athletes this guy's the
most courageous this guy's the strongest
these are all virtues but the one
indispensable
virtue is persistence the ability just
to stay in the game long enough to get
the results you seek
but what does persistence really look
like
if we can just break that apart a little
bit it's actually this is a great
question you're asking because
most people see it as a kind of
simplistic
doggedness where you just show up every
day that's not
it the most important form of
persistence
is persistence of thinking which
looks to push you in increasingly
efficient
more and more efficient methods of
training
famously people talk about the idea that
the hardest work of all is hard thinking
and they're absolutely right okay coming
into the gym and just doing the same
thing
for a decade isn't going to make you
better what's going to make you better
is progressive training over time where
you identify
clear goals marked out in time
increments 3 months 6 months 12 months 5
years
and build those short-term goals into a
program of long-term goals
um making sure that the training program
changes over time so that as your skill
level rises the challenges you face in
the gym become higher and higher
don't kill them at the start with
challenges that are too hard for them to
deal with they get discouraged and leave
build them slowly over time but make
sure they don't just get left in a swamp
where they're just doing the same thing
they were doing three years ago and they
get bored and
there's two ways you can leave in a gym
you can leave
from adversity it was too tough or you
can leave from boredom
everyone talks about the first no one
talks about the second
most people when they get to black belt
they get bored
they know what their game is they know
what they're good at they know what
they're not good at
when they compete they stick with what
they're good at and they avoid what
they're not good at
yeah and they get bored they reach a
plateau
and that's it my whole thing is to make
sure it's not so tough at the start that
they leave because of adversity
and then for the rest of their career to
make sure it's not boring so they leave
because of boredom travis diaz actually
said something that changed the way i
see training
he said it as a side comment but he said
that at the end of a training
at the end of a good training session
your mind should be exhausted not your
body
and um i've for most of my life
saw good training sessions where my body
was exhausted
yes i believe that's the case with most
people
yeah you should come out of the training
session with your mind
buzzing with ideas like possibilities
for tomorrow
and by the way on that note i would go
further and say that
the training session doesn't finish when
your body stops moving
it finishes when your mind stops moving
and your mind shouldn't stop moving
after that session there should be
analysis what did i do well what did i
do badly
how could i do better with the things
that i did well
you